>> Greg: WELCOME BACK!
SINGLE WOMEN AND THEIR CATS
MOSTLY VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS.
YES, THE 2022 ELECTION SHOWED
THE RISE OF A NEW PROGRESSIVE
VOTING BLOCK, THE SINGLE WOKE
FEMALE DEFINED AS UNMARRIED
WOMEN WITHOUT CHILDREN.
WITH "WOKE" MEANING BOTH VERY
LIBERAL AND WOKE UP ALONE NEXT
TO SOME CAT PUKE.
SO APPARENTLY THIS MEANS
DEMOCRATS ARE COMPETING FOR THE
SAME CUSTOMERS AS SWEATPANTS.
SEXISTS WOULD SAY!
[LAUGHTER]
>> DON'T CANCEL ME.
THAT WAS [BLEEP] FUNNY.
>> Greg: IN THE MIDTERM, 68%
OF THEM VOTED FOR DEMOCRATS.
THE REMAINING 32% WROTE, "I LOVE
COCONUT WATER.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COCONUT WATER?"
I THOUGHT THAT WAS BETTER!
THE GROUP IS MUCH LARGER THAN IT
USED TO BE AND NOT BECAUSE THEY
PUT ON LOCKDOWN WEIGHT, MIKE.
THE NUMBER OF MARRIED WOMEN
REACHING 30% LAST YEAR.
IT'S BAD FOR BIRTHRATE BUT IT'S
GOOD FOR SINGLE SERVE CHARDONNAY
AND LIFETIME TELEVISION IT WON'T
BE CHANGING ANYTIME SOON.
61% OF SINGLE MEN SAID THEY'RE
CURRENTLY LOOKING FOR DATES.
ONLY 38% OF SINGLE WOMEN SAID
THE SAME THING.
ALTHOUGH THAT MAY HAVE BEEN A
ROOS TO AVOID REQUESTS BY JAMIE.
WOMEN COULD DO ANYTHING MEN CAN
DO, INCLUDING HAVING A PENIS.
OH, I DON'T LIKE THAT.
KAT, YOU ARE THE FEMALE HERE.
I DON'T CONSIDER YOU WOKE AT
ALL.
ISN'T IT WEIRD?
SEEMS LIKE THESE ARE THE WORST
WOMEN FOR WOMEN BECAUSE, A, THEY
DENY SEX DIFFERENCES AND, B,
THEY DON'T GIVE ANY AGENCY FOR
WOMEN, SO WOMEN CAN'T EVEN
CONSENT TO SEX.
IT'S LIKE THEY CAN CHANGE THEIR
MIND BECAUSE THEY'RE ALWAYS
VICTIMIZED OR MARGINALIZED.
THEY CAN'T BE STRONG AND THEY
ACTUALLY CAN'T BE WOMEN.
>> THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE LIKE
THAT.
I DON'T THINK THIS DESCRIBES
EVERYONE.
I'VE BEEN A MARRIED WOMEN FOR
ONLY A YEAR AND A HALF AND I'M
34.
I WAS AN UNMARRIED CHILDLESS
WOMAN FOR A LONG TIME.
IT COULD HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
I'M PROOF OF THAT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE LIKE, I'M NOT
LOOKING.
I WAS LIKE, NEITHER WAS I.
IT'LL GET YOU.
>> Greg: YES, IT'S LIKE A
COVID STRAIN.
>> IT'LL GET YOU.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT, YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT NOT
EVERYBODY WHO IS A CONSERVATIVE
IS SOCIALLY CONSERVATIVE AND
JUDGMENTAL OF NONTRADITIONAL
LIFESTYLES BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE JUDGMENTAL OF
NONTRADITIONAL LIFESTYLES ARE
CONSERVATIVE.
AND I THINK THAT MAYBE SOME
PEOPLE CAN'T SEE PAST THOSE
THINGS AND YOU SHOULD FOCUS ON
BEING A BIT OF A BIGGER TENT AND
LESS ON SOCIAL ISSUES.
DEMOCRATS DO IT, TOO, OBVIOUSLY.
THEY GATE KEEP THEIR OWN PARTY,
TOO.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE
SAID JAMIE.
I JUST WORRY ABOUT YOU BECAUSE
YOU, UM, THIS COULD HURT YOU.
YOU NEED TO FIND A WOMAN TO TALK
TO IN YOUR GARAGE.
>> YEAH, I DON'T BELIEVE THIS.
>> Greg: NO?
>> BECAUSE I'VE BEEN LOOKING.
SO I GUESS THEY'RE ALSO LIARS.
SERIOUSLY, I DON'T EVEN FEEL
QUALIFIED TO TALK.
YOU KNOW ME.
I'M GOING TO BE SINGLE FOREVER.
I TRY.
THERE'S NOWHERE TO GO.
YOU GET FARMERSONLY.COM.
THERE'S ONLY FARMERS.
I CAN'T DO THAT I CAN'T GO ON
MATCH.COM.
I'M NOT AN ARSONIST.
I SAY SCREW IT, I WANT A
SANDWICH.
I GO TO GRINDER.COM.
I'M JUST GLAD I ORDERED THE
6-INCH.
IT SAYS RIGHT HERE --
>> Greg: HA-HA!
THAT WAS GOOD.
>> IT SAYS DO NOT SAY THAT ONE
RIGHT HERE.
IT'S TOUGH, THOUGH.
I FEEL BAD FOR THESE WOMEN.
I FEEL BAD FOR MYSELF.
DATING AFTER 40 IS LIKE MOVING
WITHOUT HIRING PROFESSIONAL
MOVERS.
THERE'S DUCTS EVERYWHERE.
THINGS DON'T FIT.
ALL THE BOXES ARE DENTED.
>> OH MY GOD!
HA-HA.
>> WHAT?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS.
>> THEY ORDERED THE BIG SUB.
>> Greg: HA-HA!
TYRUS, MOST OF YOUR FANS ARE
WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN MARRIED FOR
50 YEARS.
>> YES.
YES.
LISTEN, I DID MY PART.
I GAVE FOUR OF THEM KIDS.
I'M TRYING.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH YOU CAN DO.
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY HOURS A DAY
YOU CAN HIDE FROM YOUR PHONE.
THE PROBLEM FOR THEM IS -- HERE
IS THE DEAL.
FELLAS, WHEN WE'RE IN OUR 20'S,
WE'RE LIKE RABBITS.
WHEN WE'RE IN OUR 30'S, WE
BECOME LIKE LIONS.
WHEN WE GET IN THOSE 40'S, WE'RE
LIKE, WELL, I MADE IT THIS FAR.
WE FOCUS ON OTHER THINGS LIKE
BUILDING ON A NEW CAR OR BUYING
MY FIRST HOUSE WITH A GARAGE OR
WHATEVER IT IS.
WE NO LONGER WANT TO DEAL WITH
THE COURTSHIP.
SO GUYS START FOCUSING ON OTHER
THINGS.
SO THEN THERE'S THAT GROUP THAT
WE'RE JUST, YOU KNOW, HOW DO I
SAY THIS?
UM.
>> Greg: I'M SCARED.
>> TOO BITCHY TO GO OUT WITH SO
YOU LEAVE THEM TO THEMSELVES
THESE POOR CATS GET STUCK WITH
THEM.
THE CATS DON'T WANT THIS.
>> I HIGHLY RECOMMEND GETTING A
CAT AS A SINGLE WOMAN.
>> ALL THE PRESSURE THEY PUT ON
THE CAT.
THEY GIVE THE CAT VOICES.
HERE IS THE DIFFERENCE.
THE CAT, AS LONG AS YOU'RE
FEEDING THEM, THEY'LL STAY.
BUT WHEN YOU START FINISHING OUR
SENTENCES, WE WANT TO LEAVE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
WE HAVE LITTLE NICKNAMES.
THEY WANT TO DRESS US UP AND DO
ALL OF THAT KIND OF STUFF.
WE WANT TO GET THE HELL OUT OF
TOWN.
THE CAT IS LIKE, AS LONG AS I'M
BEING FED, THEY'LL HANG AROUND.
AS SOON AS YOU STOP FEEDING THEM
OR YOU LEAVE THE WINDOW OPEN,
THEY'RE OUT.
>> Greg: LIKE MY BAKER.
YOU LEAVE THE WINDOW OPEN, HE'S
GONE.
>> THAT'S HOW I LEAVE THE FOX
BUILDING.
JUST OPEN THE WINDOW.
>> Greg: CARE TO ADD ANYTHING
UPLIFTING ABOUT THIS?
YOU'RE A HAPPILY MARRIED MAN.
YOU'RE ON YOUR SIXTH MARRIAGE,
RIGHT?
>> YES, ME AND TONY RANDALL AND
LARRY KING.
UM, NO, I GOT [BLEEP] WHEN IT
COMES TO TALKING ABOUT SINGLE
WOKE WOMEN.
>> ELOQUENT.
>> I COULDN'T IMAGINE BEING IN
THE DATING POOL LIKE JAMIE.
I COULDN'T IMAGINE THAT.
AND I'M WORRIED FOR YOU.
>> I'M TRYING.
>> FIND A HOBBY.
FIND A HOBBY.
>> A HOBBY.
YES.
>> TRAVEL THE WORLD!
>> YOU COULD GET YOUR FRIENDS TO
HELP YOU RAISE A GARAGE.
>> Greg: WOULDN'T THAT BE
NICE?
>> YOU SHOULD GET A CAT.
>> A LOT OF THIS IS FUNNY BUT
ALSO FEELS BAD INSIDE.
>> Greg: HA-HA!
>> FEEL BETTER WITH A CA